today on the matt wall show the
organizers of a sex camp for children
are now allegedly in hiding because of
quote right-wing harassment from the
likes of ben shapiro and yours truly and
others according to the media just
because you hold masturbation workshops
for kids doesn't mean you can't be a
victim too also speaking of victims fake
victims anyway jesse smilet is released
from jail proving that few people are
more privileged in this culture than
someone who is gay black rich and famous
also a children's hospital gives advice
on tucking for kids now if you don't
know what that is you're going to find
out today and probably hate me for
telling you and a popular new song
worships ukrainian president zielenski
as a christ figure who has come to save
the world what's the problem with this
kind of over-the-top adulation of a
political figure during war time or
anytime we'll talk about all that and
more today on the matt welsh show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know we know that inflation is out
of control right now and it's really
hurting it's hurting everybody in
america and one area where we see
inflation more than ever is in the
grocery store even though grocery prices
feel like they've doubled good rancher's
prices have stayed low and affordable
once you subscribe your price never goes
up your best price is locked in for life
don't pay a premium for low quality
foreign meat shop good ranchers for all
of your beef chicken and seafood needs
good ranchers only sells 100 american
meat from local farms and ranches they
have signature steak burgers uh
they've got all kinds of meat that's
packed with flavor i've tried this stuff
myself i've had i think almost
everything that they have to offer and
um i haven't been disappointed by any of
it they're pre-trimmed and pre-marinated
chicken breasts are absolutely delicious
and so easy to prepare as well plus
their packaging makes it easy to cook
what you want and save the rest which
keeps you from wasting anything and also
keeps you from wasting money we all need
to make sure we save as much money as we
can so get your 30 discount on prime
steaks and better than organic chicken
today go to goodranchers.com welsh to
save on the quality you've been looking
for good ranchers takes the guesswork
out of the grocery store by sourcing
everything from local farms and shipping
it to your door use my code walsh and
enjoy your box of 100 american meat and
your 30 savings order now to combat
inflation with good ranchers american
meat delivered so when biden announced
his supreme court pick contanji brown
jackson the media and the democrats were
quick to hail her as a highly qualified
irreproachable candidate who should be
immediately confirmed because there's
nothing to ask her or find out about her
other than the fact that she is simply
wonderful in every way now as expected
some republicans joined in this chorus
as well celebrating jackson for her
stellar resume
even though the most important thing on
her resume as far as biden was concerned
was her gender and her skin color all in
all the consensus from dc seemed to be
that this nominee is perfect
unassailable and there's nothing else to
see here folks
well it turns out there was a little bit
more to see at least senator josh hawley
decided to buck the trend and do a bit
of homework on cantangi brown jackson
what he discovered was quite disturbing
disturbing especially because it's part
of a larger trend now in a series of
tweets last night holly revealed judge
jackson has a pattern of letting child
porn offenders off the hook for their
appalling crimes both as a judge and as
a policy maker she's been advocating for
it since law school this goes beyond
soft on crime i'm concerned this is a
record that endangers our children as
far back as her time in law school judge
jackson is questioned making convicts
register as sex offenders saying it
leads to stigmatization and ostracism
she suggested public policy is driven by
a climate of fear hatred and revenge
against sex offenders
now i will say for the record um taking
a pause here for a moment that i
actually agree
that we should get rid of the sex
offender registry but that's only
because anybody dangerous enough to be
on the registry should still be in
prison okay the registry only exists
because the courts are releasing
predators and pedophiles into our
communities who they the courts know are
a danger to the public so
rather than writing their names on a
list and putting another little red dot
on a map
these people should just be kept in
their cages to begin with
now we don't have to worry about it it's
absurd that the legal system would
actually label somebody a high-risk sex
offender and then proceed to send them
into our neighborhoods they could put a
stamp on someone saying high-risk
high-risk sex offender okay you can go
now
get rid of the sex offender registry by
extending prison sentences
that's that's my position
though jackson wants to get rid of it
for much the opposite reason uh now back
to holly it says
judge jackson has also questioned
sending dangerous sex offenders to civil
commitment we have a civil commitment
law in missouri and it protects children
it gets worse as a member of the u.s
sentencing commission judge jackson
advocated for drastic changes in how the
law treats sex offenders by eliminating
the existing mandatory minimum sentences
for child porn judge jackson has said
that some people who possess child porn
are in this for either the collection or
the people who are loners and find
status in their participation in the
community
what community would that be the
community of child exploiters judge
jackson has opined that there may be a
type of quote less serious child
pornography offender whose motivation is
not sexual but quote is the challenge or
to use the technology
a quote less serious child porn offender
in her time on the u.s sentencing
commission judge jackson said that she
quote mistakenly assumed that child
pornography offenders are pedophiles and
she wanted to quote understand this
category of non-pedophiles who obtained
child pornography
non-pedophiles
who obtain child pornography
that's like what
non-drunk drivers who happen to be
driving while intoxicated
holly continues on uh for many other
more tweets revealing many more sordid
details about this highly qualified
judge but i think you get the idea she
believes
that some people caught with child porn
aren't even pedophiles and they might
just be collectors
but no different from someone who
collects baseball cards or stamps maybe
her
reference to pedophiles as a community
is extremely disturbing because this is
the classic
thing this is a classic move by people
who wish to normalize or excuse any sort
of deviant behavior it always begins
by turning the deviants into a community
that's always the first step they're a
community
a bunch of individual predators and
perverts you know they can be condemned
but a community
well you can't say anything bad about a
community
you know the people that nobody has any
interest in excusing or validating or
legitimizing we don't talk about them as
communities like nobody talks about the
serial killer community no one says that
even though there are multiple serial
killers in in the world but we don't
talk about them as a community
the word community is used when there is
an effort to validate
and generate sympathy
that's the idea
and this again is part of a larger trend
as we've seen there are many groomers
and predators on the left and many more
who say that we should have sympathy for
these kinds of people
speaking of which you may remember last
week when we discussed the quote sexy
summer camp for children hosted by a
group of disgusting perverts in kentucky
as uncovered by chris ruffo the camp
meant for people of all ages including
kids
has lessons on sex liberation gender
exploration bdsm being a sex worker
self-managed abortions and sexual
activity while using illicit and illicit
drugs
the itinerary for the camp shows that
the very first workshop on the first day
is a lesson on self-pleasure which
includes a quote hands-on
masturbation demonstration
one of the women who hosted the camp has
been an outspoken advocate for childhood
masturbation for years you probably
remember the video that we played uh
last week where she talks about this but
if you didn't watch last week and maybe
you don't remember unfortunately i'm
gonna have to play it again and here it
is you know like get down with yourself
explore your own body masturbation is
really healthy and i recommend it to
people of all ages
all ages as soon as my nephews could
talk they were doing that that's what
they were doing kids touch themselves
kids start to ask questions and we teach
them the language for their bodies right
that's your nose touch your nose show
aunt t you can touch your nose but my
sister's not saying that when they're
tugging at their penis right but it
feels good right we have to learn ways
to talk to young people about this so
that they know how to explore their body
consensually so that it's not in public
right we don't want people exploring
their bodies in public that's not
consensual
but exploring your body at any age
grandma's grandpas all of us
uh
you know we see a lot there one of the
things we see the part part of this is
this female
privilege
because i tell you something
if that was just a dude
talking about you know as like an uncle
talking about how he uh
as likes to talk to his nieces and
nephews
about
masturbating
there would be
universal agreement that this guy is a
pedophile a predator and needs to be put
in prison and kept away from kids
now there should obviously be universal
agreement on this too
but there isn't
no there's there's agreement really just
on one side of the aisle
as i discovered when i called this out
on my show uh and so did many people on
the right to include ben shapiro some
fox hosts like laura ingraham lo and
behold turns out and as i saw last night
that we as the critics of the sex camp
for kids
have become the bad guys
and um and the groomers giving
masturbation demonstrations to children
they're the helpless victims
the feminist website jezebel published
this report
with the headline a group of sex ed
teachers are afraid for their lives amid
right-wing harassment campaign
now i should note that i found out about
this article because i was tagged in a
post by the catholics for choice page on
twitter linking to this article with
their caption which said this is
horrifying and sadly more and more
common as right-wing extremists continue
to feel more and more emboldened to
target others with their vitriolic
hatred shame on laura ingram ben shapiro
matt walsh and everyone else bullying
these teachers
now it's no surprise that the heretics
who call themselves catholic while
whoring themselves out for the abortion
industry would take the side of groomers
that doesn't surprise me at all as for
the article it says quote a group of sex
education teachers in appalachia are
afraid for their lives so much so that
they're having to hide in safe houses
after christopher ruffo the right-wing
act activist credited by the new yorker
for effectively quote inventing the
conflict surrounding critical race
theory has now set his sights on
exposing their program
since the thread was published the
program was featured on the ingram angle
was called out in an advertisement for a
populist conservative think tank and has
attracted the attention of a slew of
well-known conservatives like ben
shapiro and matt walsh
now program staffers have been doxxed on
twitter with a user on social media link
likening them to witches predators and
pedophiles and calling for their arrests
the online attacks have become so
prevalent that they've recently been
forced to seek refuge at a safe house a
source close to the women told jezebel
and an allied local pro-abortion
organization has also created a
spreadsheet to track threats of violence
and death against the staff
by the way why do you think the abortion
you're a catholics for choice a
pro-abortion organization why are they
so invested in this you think about that
why are they so invested
in sexualizing children
why do they care planned parenthood
abortion industry is very invested in
this why is that
a part of it is that they hate kids
uh they despise children they kill them
they see children as as uh
not just just
things to be exploited
but also because
the more that they can encourage sexual
activity younger and younger
than the more customers they're going to
have
to clarify something else some of these
women
you know we're accused of calling them
witches but actually these women call
themselves witches
now i probably would have still called
them witches because they are even if
they didn't identify as such but um
that's irrelevant now back to the
article it says since last tuesday sexy
sex ed uh our this is a
quote now from the group since last
tuesday
sexy sex ed our educators and our
funders have been flooded with hundreds
of threatening messages across all
platforms the group wrote in a statement
on their website
we recognize that the current
misinformation attack against sexy sex
ed is part of a long-term highly funded
and coordinated strategy of the right to
maintain and entrench their power
through media and narrative control
now the statement from the sex camp
workers is lengthy and calls me out by
name along with ruffo and ben shapiro um
i can't speak for those other two but
i'm quite sure that they would join me
in laughing hysterically at the very
idea
that we owe these women an apology or
any sort of sympathy at all
i also don't believe by the way that
they got the kind of threats that would
require them to go to safe houses i
don't believe that okay i just don't
believe it
um i get threats all the time much more
than they do and i've never fled to a
safe house because of them
now regardless i don't condone threats
or violence but the general anger
directed at these predators
is due entirely to their own actions
nobody forced them to hold masturbation
and bdsm workshops for kids
they had to think of that in their own
dark twisted little disgusting brains
and make the choice to put their bizarre
fantasies into practice
what they didn't expect is that anybody
outside of their community
their community quote unquote
of weirdo perverts would notice
or hold them accountable
but
this is what evil does
when it's exposed it shrinks away
scurries off to the corner like
cockroaches plays the victim
manipulates woe is me
it's a dishonest game and a repulsive
tactic
but
it means we're pointing the light
exactly where it needs to be
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well with the ever-increasing numbers of
car makes and models it's basically
impossible to stock all the parts you
need in a traditional chain storefront
so that's why there's no reason to go
and just walk around aimlessly looking
for the vehicle that you need and then
you have to go and talk to the
counterman and order the parts on his
computer anyway you have computers with
access to rockauto.com at home and in
your pocket why would you choose to
spend 30 50 100 more for the exact same
auto parts at a chain store or a new car
dealership uh there's no reason to do
that rockauto.com is a family business
they've been serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years you can go
to rockauto.com to shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers they have everything that
you might need from engine control
modules and brake parts they've got
motor oil new carpet everything you
could possibly need the rockauto.com
catalog is unique and remarkably easy to
navigate quickly see all the parts
available for your vehicle and choose
the brand specifications and prices you
prefer
best of all prices at rockauto.com are
always reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers go
to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car or truck
and write walsh in their how did you
hear about us box so they know that we
sent you
all right um
i i also love the uh the claim that we
we engaged in misinformation but we know
that that word like so many other words
pretty much any word that the left
commonly uses it
they all the fact that they're using it
so often means that they've removed it
of all meaning because uh they never use
any words as they're supposed to be used
so misinformation is one of those and
we're accused of a misinformation
campaign literally what what chris ruffo
did is he he found their actual program
and videos of them speaking and said
here's what's happening here's their
actual program from their sex camp for
kids and it's a list at all
a very uh you know just right right
there you can read it this is
the first workshop the second
and so for him to take that and say look
everybody here's this thing this thing
that's happening
much of which they got from their own
website
that that's misinformation
um
let's start with this from cnn jesse
smallet was released from jail wednesday
night after an illinois appeals court
granted an emergency motion by his
defense attorney smilet's legal team is
looking to delay his sentence and grant
him bond until their appeal of his
conviction is decided on the former
empire actor was sentenced last week to
30 months of felony probation including
150 days in jail
um
and
including some restitution as well quote
there's no room for politics in our
court system defense attorney nenya uche
said in a news conference shortly after
the actor's release regardless of what
you think about this case the real
question is should black men be walked
into jail for a class iv felony
that's a disgrace the attorney added
and uh
they get to the reason for
this release there isn't there there
wasn't much reason given
um
by the court for why they're releasing
justice malet from prison
we know the real reason which we'll get
to in a second
um as far as any reason what they what
they basically say is that
well the appeal is going to take a long
time
and it's only 150 days in jail so
he'll he'll he's appealing the sentence
and by the time the appeals decided the
sentence will be over anyway so we're
just going to let him out of jail
by that logic
well i guess we're never going to send
anybody to jail again for the
six month sentences i guess are out the
window now because that's always going
to be the case that if you appeal it uh
the appeal will take longer than the
sentence
so is that what that means we can't we
can't send anybody to jail for for that
amount of time
this only further affirms what what i
said immediately after this sentence was
passed down
and there were people talking about even
people who who were happy that he was
going to jail were saying oh that's
pretty harsh sentence uh you know
no it should have been much more than
that
he should have been looking at five 10
15 years
for all the reasons that we've talked
about
given that he's given that he's
unrepentant
um
given the just sociopathic nature of the
everything that went into the
premeditation
as i pointed out many times the fact
that he was he was willing to let
innocent people take the fall for him
um all of that perjured himself on the
stand
you know was was trying to inflame
racial tensions would have been fine if
there was uh if there was a riot in
chicago over this
he would not only would have been fine
with it he was he would have been happy
about it he probably was upset that
there was no riot
that's yet another thing that makes him
a victim is that people weren't rioting
over it
so you take all that consideration you
could easily justify the max prison
sentence which would have been as the
sentencing judge admitted 15 years and
he should have gotten all 15 years
and then at least they can't release him
from jail on the excuse that
the appeal will take longer than the
sentence
uh but now he's out of jail and
his defense attorney says well should we
be should we be marching should we
should we be walking uh black men into
jail for class four felonies
let me answer that question for you
if i could the answer is uh yes
why shouldn't we be
why shouldn't we be
walking black men into jail for class 4
felonies
but the law stipulates that you can go
to jail for those kinds of crimes
now you notice the only thing that the
defense attorney's worried about is
black men so white men we can march oh
yeah well they can go to jail but black
men how dare we put black men
in jail
he's almost admitting
just by saying that he's almost
admitting
what we all know to be true anyway
that despite all the talk about white
privilege and everything else
there is privilege in this country
there's no question about it
there are people who are privileged in
many different ways
you know there's the basic kind of
privilege that comes with being wealthy
and having a lot of money and being
famous justice mullet has all that
there's also the privilege that comes
tied to identity there is racial
privilege there is identity-based
privilege
and it's privilege that you ex you
experience in the culture in society
by through social advantages and you
also experience it in the courtroom
but we're not giving that privilege out
to white people
unless they can claim some other
privileged identity for them now a white
person who says he's gay or trans sure
he'll get some privilege
but the reality is that jesse smallett
as a black
gay
rich famous person
is almost as privileged as you can
possibly get
and that's exactly how he's gotten away
with all of this
got away with doing all of this and
getting on the stand
and perjuring himself lying to the court
for hours on end which the sentencing
judge mentioned that and pretended to be
upset about it
that's almost as privileged as you could
possibly get in our society today the
only thing that would make jesse
smallett more privileged is if he was
trans that's the one thing that's the
one
advantage the one card he hasn't played
yet yet i mean emphasis on yet
and maybe
my guess is that
now that he's out of jail
and all the legal problems are gonna be
put behind him you know the next thing
that he's going to want is he's going to
want to get back into hollywood and
start starring in films again
and i think though and i i think he'll
have no problem doing that
but if he really wants to make sure that
hollywood embraces him and he can get
his whole life back and maybe even
benefit from this in the end uh than
just come out as trans
so that's my guess in the next couple of
years justice millet
jesse smallett will become jessica
smolet in the next couple of years that
is my uh
my my guess
maybe jesse is already a gender-neutral
name so he doesn't need to change it so
it's all it's already all set up for
okay it's from the daily wire it says
dornebecker children's hospital in
portland which bills itself as oregon's
top-ranked
uh children's hospital boasts a gender
clinic which offers advice for the safe
tucking of a boy's genitals
out of the way quote unquote that can
make quote the general area look
smoother and flatter as well as a
referral to a quote sex positive shop in
portland
they sell gender affirming clothe items
as well as sex toys videos and more
there's a children's hospital referring
children to a sex shop
while also giving them tips on tucking
what's that all about well the resource
on safe tucking from the gender clinic
states quote
safe tucking what is tucking talking is
moving the penis testicles are both out
of the way this makes the genital area
look smoother and flatter tucking can
reduce any concerns you have about your
body how your clothes fit and how safe
you feel in public people of all genders
can tuck there are several different
methods of tucking the information below
helps you tuck in ways that are safe for
your body
according to the hospital's website it
works in cooperation with the
oregon health and science university
transgender health program
the ohsu logo is also emblazoned on the
safe tucking handout
the handout cautions quote a note on the
words we use
this information uses the words penis
scrotum and testicles we know you may
not use those terms or identify with
them we use them here to refer to body
parts that people with tucking needs
have
people with tucking needs
while understanding those words are not
for everyone
the resource advises it is best to talk
for the first time when you're planning
to be at home this keeps you from
stressing about having to get get it
right the first time it's also easier to
learn what your body needs to be
comfortable when you tuck choose a
method that feels comfortable for to you
and i just can't even keep reading this
absolutely revolting and this is a
children's hospital
this is
you hear me talk about this issue all
the time because
you you know that i believe
that um gender ideology and especially
its effects on kids this is
probably the number one issue we face as
a society right now
um
but even as much as i talk about it
if you listen to the show
you still probably
don't quite comprehend
just how bad this is
how widespread this madness is
um
how ubiquitous how ingrained it has
become
i don't think anyone even i can't fully
comprehend it
because i'm i'm living through it
and it's the kind of thing that you
can't fully understand it's like it's a
historical you know anytime you're
living through a historical period or
some sort of historical event
you you the people who are in it can't
they don't have the view of it that you
have when you're
later when you can look back
um
and so even for me it's it's it's
impossible to fully comprehend
what we are doing
to ourselves and especially to our kids
i mean what this this generation
that we're raising right now what is
what's this generation going to look
like
in 30 years
how many of them are still going to be
here
because a huge portion
tell you one thing we're going to see
and we're already starting to see now
and it's only going to get worse
mass suicide epidemic
among these kids
who who we have taken
and when i say we i mean society
has has taken and
forced an identity crisis onto them
and completely from the youngest age is
completely
morphed and deformed their their i
concept of themselves
and put them on a path towards
destroying and rejecting their own
bodies
to a point where eventually they're
going to look back and so much damage
has been done that can't be undone and
they're going to say who am i what am i
what have what have i done what have you
all as the adults allowed me to do what
have you done to me
and we're going to see a wave of despair
and suicide unlike anything the world
has ever seen before
again we're already seeing it
it's only going to get worse the wave is
going to become a tsunami
and don't don't comfort yourself by
saying well this is a children's
hospital in oregon
it's not the only children's hospital
but it's a children's hospital
a hospital
telling kids to do this
now i don't think i need to get into an
explanation of why
giving tucking tips
to little boys
is um
reprehensible and disgusting and
horrible
one of the reasons
is that
we are encouraging our kids
again to reject themselves reject their
own bodies
it's really the exact opposite of the
message that most of us grew up with
especially you know the millennial
generation back when i was a kid and
none of this stuff existed nobody was
talking about any of this
but back then there was this
huge emphasis on
embracing yourself and loving yourself
and your own body an emphasis that that
oftentimes went went way overboard and
went into the realm of you know
narcissism and encouraging
uh people to be
sort of self-obsessed
but at least it was on the right path
okay we
we
sometimes it went too far and we didn't
go about it the right way all the time
but it was the right path
where you're at least telling people
okay this is who you are this is your
body it's the only one you're ever going
to get
so you should accept that
accept who you are
you should love who you are
love the body that god has given you
the message now for kids is
exactly the opposite of that
and i'll tell you something else
um
the people who
see this kind of thing
are giving tucking tips to kids in a
children's hospital the people who see
this and approve of it
uh
i don't want to share a country with
them
i don't want to be united with them
they are not my brothers and sisters
in the in this country they're not my
friends
i don't want to be their friends
i i don't even want to be cordial
towards them we can't even be cordial
like if you're around me and i know that
you're that kind of person who would
approve of something like this i can't
respect you as a human being
i don't want to be near you
i don't want to have a conversation with
you about anything
you disgust me
you are an evil twisted sick person
that's where we are in this country
and i don't see how it gets any better
all right let's see what else do we got
here um
we'll play this for you this week the
senate committee on health education
labor and pensions voted on an amendment
that would
block the government from enforcing mass
usage and vaccines for preschoolers and
toddlers i want to play this clip for
you quickly and just listen to this and
tell me what you hear
and next we have braun amendment number
eight
to prevent hhs from implementing or
enforcing their regulations regarding
mask or vaccination protections in the
head start program again i will be a no
on this does anyone want senator braun's
15 seconds
seeing none
clerk call the rule
senator romney
there's senator romney with the uh with
the no which means that he's he doesn't
want to stop the government from
forcing masks and vaccines on toddlers
he's he's in favor of doing that
as a as a republican
this is the republican party all right
moving on quickly another clip i want to
play for you before we get to the
comment section um
i don't exactly know why but we got it
we need a little bit of levity here we
need something a little bit less serious
so kim kardashian
was you can't get less serious than that
she was on with ellen and apparently
ellen degeneres still has a show i
thought that she got run out of town and
her show was canceled but apparently not
she's been doing a show and she was um
interviewing kim kardashian talking
about her
wonderful romance with pete davidson and
this is what she said listen
there's a tattoo that says kim
um yeah he has a few tattoos few cute
ones you know that he got
but this one is a it's not that one the
kim one isn't a tattoo it's actually a
branding
like a
branding
because let me explain it because he
wanted to do something that was really
different because like okay first tattoo
we got i was like oh so cute thank you
oh my god you know second whatever i'm
like oh that's so cute but like that's
what tattoo people do right like they
get tattoos of what's going on in their
life and
way back that's like that that's special
you said first tattoo
so he has three tattoos of you
it sounds like this is like the third
so the first tattoo was you said kind of
cute so yeah
is it your name or is it like a little
branding is my name right the other ones
are like cutesy things i think my
favorite one
it says here it says my girl is a lawyer
is she a lawyer
is kim kardashian a lawyer
that's and there's a lot of information
coming out on the show that i don't
think anyone wanted to know one of them
is a kim kardashian somehow has a law
degree apparently
so kanye west is the mentally ill one
here
and yet pete davidson
is getting branded with his girlfriend's
name
and kanye west is a problem though
here's the here's the proper response
when you're dating someone and they get
a tattoo of your name
it's just as soon as it's a real it's a
real simple thing
you're dating someone
and uh they say you're sitting down with
them somewhere and they say hey check
out this tattoo i got it's your name all
you do very simply is you just get up
and you walk away and never talk to that
person ever again
um
now they get three tattoos and that even
and a branding even more so
that would be that would be the proper
response but of course kim kardashian's
a
uh herself a raging narcissist obviously
so she thinks oh yeah of course you're
gonna get bran the whole world should be
branded with my name
as far as she's concerned
all right one other quick headline this
is from the new york post it says a
comet's
16 miles wide
is heading towards earth that's the
headline
so this is not the this is different
from the one that was the the size of a
giraffe or a rather a half giraffe this
is one of 16 miles wide and uh it's it's
heading towards earth
my question is when i read this the
first thing that i thought i know you
had the same thought i know for
you know many people in the media of
course had this thought but the first
thing i thought 60 mile wide comet
heading towards earth
how is this going to affect the lgbt
community
like marginalized communities are gonna
be disproportionately impacted that's my
main concern by this earth destroying
comet
turns out by the way that when you uh
when you click on the article that it's
the comet is heading towards earth but
it's just gonna it's gonna orbit around
and then go somewhere else so it's not
actually gonna hit the earth
just another click bait another click
bait uh asteroid article it gets all of
our hopes up as usual
let's get to the comment section
[Music]
[Music]
sweet baby comments do we have anything
worth watching from there let's try clip
seven
hey sweet daddy
so i'm getting ready to watch your show
and yesterday i did a little search on
ernest shackleton because i was so
inspired the other day
and knowing
how much my public school education had
failed me i am going to
continue the journey on my own and read
this book
but i noticed
this nice little comment on audible
uh from matthew 104
saying i listened to this one in the car
on my way to and from work each day
and as the end approached i would sit in
my car and listen i couldn't bring
myself to turn off the player i even
cried
twice
i never cry
just wondering if that's you
anyways
uh have a good show today oh one more
thing
i uh purple nurpled my husband until he
called you sweet daddy
so
yeah
sweet baby gang for life
uh the bit at the end there was just
with that's that's when we get into the
tmi range i'm not sure that i needed
that
actually i thought see i this is written
on the clip sheet it says uh
did you write this amazon review so i
thought it was gonna be a review for my
own book johnny the walrus would be a
good plot product placement but
anyway uh no i i look
this is not it's not it is it's an
affecting book
um it's a good book
but we've gone through the list the
appropriate reasons for men to cry and
um a book didn't make the list
unless we're talking about the bible i i
have to allow it for that if you're
overcome even there don't overdo it but
if you're reading the bible and the
spirit is moving you then i i ca i just
i can't judge you for that
without incurring uh the wrath of the
almighty so i'll allow it for that but
no other book all right
i'm being told that clip 9 is good
is it good
it's a minute and 27 seconds
you're telling me this is good okay i
mean mckenna is in my ear right now
promising me that this one minute 27
second clip
will actually be good
so she's on the hook here
okay let's watch hey mr boss it's me
it's uncle murray you know i was looking
through your store and i didn't see no
little mad wall figurines or something
from my dashboard so i thought okay i
guess i'm gonna have to make one myself
i figured i'd carve my own little daddy
maddie out of a stick of wood he'll
watch i'll show you see that's gonna be
you you got your leprechaun head for st
patrick's day okay here we go well
that's the rough out of you if your
tools are sharp enough you can go in
sideways like a ninja if i don't trim
that off it'll look like you got okay
does he actually carve the thing was he
carving from your tushy all the way down
right that actually carves me fast
forward to the end where i see myself
now i'm working
leprechaun and you let your beard grow
out a little manlier right wow that's
easy that is actually impressive i can't
even tell the difference listen okay i'm
matt wells i like it
okay
okay fine i'm i am we didn't need a
minute 27 seconds of that but he
actually carved that whole thing huh
that that that takes talent
i'll give him that
but please
stop sending your comments in all the
same
uh let's see sydney mercedes says matt
you're banned if you if you make us
listen to that song about zelinski
that's cruel and unusual punishment well
as you know if i have to endure these
things so do you so stay tuned for the
daily cancellation
curly says uh matt evolution only occurs
within a species not between species
herschel was entirely correct
well he wasn't because he misstated what
the theory is and that was my point
yesterday is that uh if you want to take
this on you know as a christian
as a political candidate for some reason
you feel like you got to talk about
evolution
um you want to take on this issue you
need to at least
understand what the theory is especially
if you're going to take the skeptical
side of it
uh because if you misrepresent
what it is then
what you're not achieving anything
you're just going to get mocked and no
one's going to listen to your critique
and uh and all of that so
he he just he didn't understand what the
theory actually states uh and that's the
problem
heart for kids says i love how you drop
draw a sharp breath and then say all
right when transitioning from one
headline to the next it's sweet
now you just made me feel weird about it
i can't even
now i just feel straight i feel weird
about so many things that have happened
in the last five minutes
uh
brian bauer says i was about to
unsubscribe when matt said he didn't
approve of the daylight savings time
change but i didn't realize they were
talking about keeping it permanently in
place once again i should always realize
whenever i think that matt is talking
about a subject i should wait to hear
what his correct assessment is before
continuing with life well thanks brian
for pointing that out because there were
a lot of people in the comments that
were disagreeing with me
um
and because they they didn't understand
again they didn't understand what what
what what
congress had done they didn't abolish
daylight savings time they have made it
permanent so they've taken this failed
government policy and they've said that
now
we're stuck with it forever
abolishing it would be good they did the
opposite of that
and finally sean says only matt walsh
would get this worked up over daylight
savings time you're going to give
yourself an aneurysm bro that's my charm
though if i have any charm at all it's
about it's because i get worked up about
insignificant things isn't it
tonight is ben's third thursday book
club and you've still got a chance to
sign up if you haven't yet he'll be
taking members through his analysis of a
tale of two cities by charles dickens
remember this is a live experience where
you get to engage with him like never
before here's the thing even if you
haven't read the book you'll feel well
read by the time you're done if anyone
should be serving as your guide when it
comes to the most important works of
literature and existence it's ben
when you sign up you'll also get his
notes which is a cheat sheet to
important lessons themes and characters
and remember you're doing all this with
thousands of daily wire members live
and again the really good thing is that
you don't have to read the book you just
watch ben you get the notes and then
from then on you can pretend that you've
read it and if anyone challenges you and
says oh yeah what happened in that book
well you've got the notes and you can
impress them that way so sign up for the
third thursday book club at third
thursdaybookclub.com to get ben's notes
sent straight to your inbox for tail two
cities and set a reminder to join the
conversation tonight at 8 pm eastern
also
as you all well know at this point the
daily wire does not stop creating
awesome new content and we're super
excited about our latest docu-series
fauci unmasked the show exposes the most
successful failure in government history
dr anthony fauci hosted by our very own
michael knowles he'll peel back the mask
on fouchy's past and show the world's
leading quote scientist for what he
really is a fraud the second episode
dropped this morning and reveals just
how ineffectively the world's leading
disease expert handled every crisis from
swine flu to anthrax and everything in
between uh just get a taste of it here's
a quick sneak peek
he's the highest paid employee in our
federal government
and beginning in the spring of 2020
dr fauci began to set national policy
that affected the way that 330 million
americans lived their lives for goodness
sakes i'm telling you wear a mask keep
social distancing there's nothing
political about that but who is anthony
fauci people who have conspiracy
theories those are people that don't
particularly care for me in this short
series
we will do what the establishment media
have refused to do
we will give you an unvarnished look at
the career of the most powerful
politician in america
dr anthony fountain don't you think it's
time that you step down and let someone
else who has a more effective message
actually no
the latest part of the three-part series
drops tomorrow and it's available
exclusively at the daywire if you're not
a member yet head to dailywire.com
subscribe to join today the show is
excellent and since we're only adding
more content every day you don't want to
miss it so make sure you go check that
out now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
well as previously mentioned or maybe
threatened the daily cancellation today
begins with a musical tribute from the
admittedly quite talented john um
odranzik said you pronounce it
on jurassic whatever his stage name is
five for fighting um he wrote this song
called can one man save the world for
and about president zelinski ukraine
it's been shared all over social media
and hailed by many people including many
conservatives some of whom i respect as
a stirring beautiful and well-deserved
homage to the leader of ukraine newsweek
catalogued some of these tearful
reactions in an article headline can one
man save the world song about zelensky
takes internet by storm the article
notes that
the singer has performed the song on
television as well and
everywhere it's played
the audience becomes overwhelmed with
warm emotions
now you could decide for yourself
whether it's worthy of that sort of
reaction
let's take a listen
who is this comedian his audience more
mice than men the superman ukrainian i
don't know
great grandson of the holocaust an
eastern heart the west has lost nail or
carry up his cross i don't know
but he's got everyone thinking
yeah he's got all of us thinking
can one man save the world in a thousand
years
will they say your name or is this all
in vain
can one man save the world
[Music]
all right so
it's possible that i'm hearing things
hallucinating but i could have sworn
that the song presents zelensky as
superman
christ carrying his cross
and a messiah who can save the whole
world
and that's just the first verse
i didn't listen to the rest of it but i
assume it ends with a modified version
of the lord's prayer you know our
zelensky which art in ukraine
now i agree with the general consensus
that it is is good and admirable for
zolensky to stay and fight for his
country
that's great of course the only other
option
right is to abandon your country and
flee into the night which would be an
act of unspeakable cowardice so
zolensky has chosen not to be an
unspeakable coward
and that's good
um doesn't make him jesus christ though
or superman
and it's important to point that out not
for the sake of cheap cynicism but for
one thing because the zelinski adulation
was already teetering on the edge of
sacrilege and deification and has
officially fallen over that edge now and
is is is in a state of blasphemous
freefall
i shouldn't need to explain why you know
talking about political leaders this way
is to borrow a favorite leftist buzzword
problematic
um especially from a moral and
theological perspective but you know
apparently we do and for another thing
when you hail somebody as a blameless
hero a literal superman a savior figure
who's fighting to save the world and
redeem all of mankind as many people
have done with zolensky and not just
through this song
you've made it impossible to think
critically about him
about what he's doing and saying and
especially about what he wants us to do
for his sake
this is a perilous moment for the world
things could go any number of different
ways and and some of them bad
and some of them very very extremely
catastrophically bad
we are in a position where
nothing really good is going to happen
but it's a question of how bad is it
going to be
what we need now in a moment like this
are sober minds
and people who are capable of careful
reflection we need prudence
but that's out the window when you're
literally bowing at the feet of one of
the people involved and worshipping him
as some kind of demigod a deity made
flesh
this kind of thing is not just cringey
and annoying though it is that
it's also the sort of thoughtless
hysterical overzealous emotionally
driven mentality that leads people to do
very stupid thing now as a general rule
there's absolutely nothing good that
ever comes out of making supermen out of
political figures
and there's especially nothing good that
especially nothing good that comes of it
when you do that during wartime of all
times
now if we can keep our wits about us
and stop with the slack-jawed drooling
over zelensky stop being a bunch of fan
girls
treating a foreign politician like he's
a pop star in concert and we're in the
front row reaching out our hands and
hoping that he that he touches us
if we can knock that off and be grown
adults for a change but i think maybe
this is the picture of zilenski that
might take shape
he's a political leader
whose country has been eva invaded
he's trying to fight to defend his home
that's good
beyond that
most of us don't really know anything
else about him most of us had never
heard his name or thought about him for
even a second prior to three weeks ago
what else has he done in ukraine what is
his personal history
what was his role in the lead-up to this
conflict
these are details that the vast majority
of americans don't have
the lack of information as always should
be reason for caution
not reason for assuming that everything
we don't know must not matter because if
it did we would know it
but here's something else that we do
know about zolensky he is actively
pushing
to get us involved in a conflict which
would certainly lead to thousands of our
sons and daughters dying and might lead
to many more deaths than that
potentially millions of deaths
zolensky wants us to incur those costs
wants us to sacrifice our children's
lives potentially for him and for his
country and for his people
there's no reason to think that he would
do the same for us but he wants us to do
that for him that you can't blame him
for wanting this kind of assistance
you can't blame him for caring more
about ukraine and his people than he
does about the united states and our
people
most most people in this country
obviously don't blame him for that and
neither do i and yet the same people in
the us who don't blame zelensky for
caring more about ukraine than the
united states do blame americans who
care more about the united states than
ukraine
it's completely perverse and backwards
according to these sad self-loathing
patsies
the only people in the whole world who
should not prioritize their own nation's
safety over the safety of other nations
are americans
everybody else can put their people
first
we cannot
this kind of confused thinking only
becomes worse and and uh and more
confused when you mix it with the
deification of foreign leaders
zelensky wants us to sacrifice an
indefinite number of american lives for
him if we insist on seeing zielinski as
a faultless martyr as a saint a sort of
cinematic protagonist then we're not
going to be able to evaluate those
demands with the clear-headed temperate
disposition that's required
we're likely to march our way into
bloodshed and suffering and death with
our eyes not open but closed imagining
some sort of fantasy scenario that's
only vaguely related to the real world
one other point every time i make this
argument
i'm accused of lacking compassion for
the suffering people of ukraine
just as one example yesterday a guy
named noam blum
an allegedly conservative media figure
took me to task on twitter writing quote
if matt walsh were capable of spending a
tenth of the emotional energy he does
being pissed zelinski on showing some
legitimately passionate passionate human
empathy to the suffering going on he
wouldn't be matt walsh i guess
i guess for blum and many others
i haven't spent nearly enough time
tweeting hashtags about how i stand with
ukraine
i've ruthlessly refused to put a
ukrainian flag in my bio or buy a
ukrainian flag t-shirt
lots of other people have done this
you know i'm not sure why i need to do
it too that's one thing i don't
understand if you see everyone doing and
saying something
why do you need if there's a couple
people not doing what do you need them
for
is there not is there not enough of that
already
i'm not sure what it achieves or how any
of this virtue signaling helps the
people of ukraine
yeah i mean i could i could
uh
defuse that
criticism
by just tweeting out hashtag i stand
with ukraine okay
what does that do
who does that help
except me i guess in that i can display
my virtue
i don't see that it helps anything and
at any rate my focus is on making sure
that america doesn't get sucked into a
conflict that could spread that misery
misery and suffering to our shores
and that's not selfishness on my part
because it's not just myself that i'm
worried about i'm worried about america
and americans
it's not a me first mentality it's an
america first mentality
and we as americans must have that
attitude because if we don't prioritize
our own people's safety and security
then nobody else will
but i must also note that as blam
attacks me for not saying enough
publicly about the suffering people of
ukraine
he himself has so far as i can tell
never said anything at all about the
suffering people of mozambique
that's also a war-torn country where
many innocent men women and children
live amid violence and untold misery
literally untold misery because nobody
talks about it
nobody talks about the vast majority of
the victims of genocide and war and
violence and disease across the planet
what's happening to ukraine right now i
got to tell you is not the first war
we've seen
in recent times even this year
well do those people not count are they
less important
see if you only express compassion and
empathy for the suffering people in
countries that get american media
attention
you might want to consider the
possibility that your compassion and
empathy are completely fake and
meaningless
you feel intense compassion for
whichever group of people the media is
talking about and then you stop thinking
about them the second the new cycle
moves on to somebody else
you get caught up in these waves
and then you have the audacity to get
self-righteous about it blaming others
for not virtue signaling as
enthusiastically as you are
it's absurd but it's worse than absurd
because this wave we're in right now is
threatening to send us crashing into a
world war
and then we'll really see some death and
suffering
much closer to home
and that's why empty virtue signaling
and zelinski worship are both today
i must say canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pavo vadowsky
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22.
today on the benton shapiro show the
federal reserve signals a bevy of rate
hikes coming as the economy teeters on
the brink of recession plus ukrainian
president vladimir zelinski begs for
more help as the russian offensive
continues to stall that's today on the
ben shapiro shall give it a listen